welcome to this video a new series about
endgame basics and endgame theory yeah
what is the meaning and game basics and
theory yeah and they look at end games
we can actually distinguish between two
things
strategic endgame this is at least how I
call it where we have many pieces on the
board or where there is some complexity
in it like both the sides have to two
minor pieces in a couple of pawns a
complex rook endgame those kind of
things cannot easily be evaluated in a
scientific manner so you can not easily
say it so we need to draw and this is
not the case for very very simplified
positions rook and pawn against look for
example King and pawn end games or
sometimes sometimes rügen games like two
against one and so on they can be not
easily but very often clearly be
evaluated with the win with the draw and
those basic endgame positions however
simple they may look it's very very
useful and essential to know them
especially if you consider that nowadays
the trend is clearly shifting towards
quicker time controls and there you very
often will be faced with the task to
convert the winning position with very
little time and it's very useful to know
lots of theoretical positions so that
you can simply reproduce what you know
and not yeah you don't need to reinvent
the wheel over the board but you simply
know what's what's going to happen and I
was arguing a bit with myself how basic
should I start and then the entire I
decided to start super basic with the
simple checkmates it's a for better
players you can simply fast-forward and
might
think that one or two episodes here are
not useful to you but I guarantee you
they will be useful later when we come
to two more as a little bit more complex
king opponent games or new game games
this video also contains meeting with
two bishops and mating with Bishop and
night so this is also may be useful even
for somewhat more advanced players and I
just want to have this in for the sake
of completeness if you feel bored simply
skip fast-forward and I guarantee you
there are people who actually benefit
from this okay we start with simply
mating with with the Queen and this is
the most basic made of course if you
cannot do that you have a hard time to
have a winner chess game the basic
principle of course is that king and
queen need to work together
the queen of course being the strongest
piece is able to set up a barrier for
the black king with this kind of squares
control to the black king is severely
limited and what white must do is
combine forces there are many ways to
meet here but the easiest is to use both
pieces so King f4 is a good idea
activating the King the black has very
little very little moves King probably
should move to f6 or to have seven and
then why does able to gain much more
space one way to do it is a queen to d6
check forcing the black King backwards
here or here the only squares available
so probably King to g7 and now white use
assisting again King to g5 advancing the
King and now black can only step back on
the eighth-ranked or stay on f7 or h7 so
probably here and now white takes the
seventh rank always controlling
important squares this is done by the
king and black only can step backwards
after which the White King advances
the king on the six rank and now the
king control what's the important
squares to deliver the checkmate
it's very important to know that the
only way to make Lex King is in
cooperation with Queen and King
you never can make the King with the
Queen alone that simply not possibly
always need your king to support the
Queen and very often you can use also
silent moves non check moves to to make
progress for example here where I said
King Queen d6 there's also Queen d7 for
example covering important squares only
this is possible now and now Queen d7
again aside and move keeping control
King needs to go here King an f5 King h5
and checkmate checkmate this is another
way to checkmate the queen is coming on
the side of the board and White King is
helping so mating was the queen is
relatively simple you can reach a mate
and very little very little moves I'm
not quite sure I think six or seven
moves even from the from the worst
possible starting position not totally
sure okay now let's check mating with
the single rook mating with the rook
it's the same principle the rook is
setting up a barrier for blacks King
setting up a cage of you if you want to
call it like that and we need to
cooperate rook and King to push blacks
King on the side of the board in the
corner the only spots where we can meet
the King as always the side of the board
or in the corner yeah let's start King
c4 is a good move now blacks King is
forced to move here you either can step
back which represents again
for us or I can step to the side after
which we can gain more space with rook
t4 or Roxy six check let's do it with
Roxy six check Jack gaining more space
blacks King now needs to go back and now
we see that we have severely closed down
blacks black space King if I'm using the
King King c7 and now we can gain even
more more room or let's say limit black
space even more look g6 is one way to do
it let's do it like that we don't need
to necessarily play the quickest way if
we want to play it safe King b7 note
that there's much less room for blacks
King then then that he had and then the
start of the start of the position rooks
e6 e7
King c57 can be v King a7 and here we go
Jack gaining the decisive space that
that we need King 8 King b6 King b8 yeah
and now very nice the lower thing if
played frost believe it was black black
two moves it is our move with white but
if it was black to move he needed to
play King eight and then we have the
checkmate so we just need to loosen with
it's the rook on the sea fog King eight
checkmate and we deliver the checkmate
the mate with the rook is very similar
to the mate with the Queen actually with
the rook we mostly play it in a way that
king and rook are very close to one
another the king is very often
protecting the rook like heaven like we
have seen here and hoping and helping
the
the black to to limit the black king in
its a cage that is going to be smaller
and smaller and move after move some
mating with the rook is it's not very
difficult most two examples normally
mastered by ohm by every chess player I
am it's very won't find many players who
cannot made with the rook or the Queen
but it gets more difficult with the
minor pieces let's now check the mate
with two bishops yeah mating with two
bishops here we have a sample position
how does white mate with two bishops
it's also not that difficult mating with
Bishop Knight is far more difficult in
in comparison
how does white do it he wants to set up
the typical cage situation that we have
seen before where the minor pieces and
and the King combined push blacks King
towards the edge of the board we can
again only mate them the edge of the
board
the typical way to do it is to set up
both bishops on eject on squares let's
go ahead and do that so okay I need to
change the side to move Jack it's not
really important but let's start let's
start with this check here like I'm
stepping aside and we want to have the
bishops positioned like that yeah on to
eject and squares here we see that the
two bishops present a barrier for the
King black absolutely cannot escape this
and what we need to do is to make this
cage smaller and smaller together with
the King yeah okay
like it does not have much to do here
and will shuffle yeah
and now we got a chance we can now make
this cage smaller be sure to e5 yeah
again we have hoops we have we have
gained something black needs to step
back and with Bishop d5 we again set up
this position with the two bishops near
each other
King b7 j f5 King is 7 and Bishop e6
it's the same thing look at this and the
black King needs to step to the edge of
the board where we want him where we
will be meeting him yeah here we we go
to f6 he cannot escape on this side so
he needs to go to evade King g6 King eh
and here we see that we are very close
to to getting the King unfortunately
it's our move so we have no way to get
him to the side quickly if we give this
check track he will escape giving a
check generally it's not a great idea
here we just want to make sure that this
sketch is getting smaller and smaller
and the King is pushed towards the
corner we have a good tempo here we just
play the bishop on this diagonal Bishop
h3g 4 is the same thing now it is black
smooth we have given him the hopes the
right to move and he must play King f8
yeah and now it's actually quite easy
Bishop d7 controlling the square so it
must go to g8
now Bishop e7 controlling f8 so he has
to step on the side yeah and now we only
need one temple move again we retreat
this bishop and he only has King g8 we
should be like check King to h8 and
Bishop Knight f6 mate this is the way to
mate with two bishops the important
thing is keep in mind and free and go
all the way back keep in mind this type
of position those two bishops on eject
and squares they set up the typical cage
and this only needs to be be continued
until the King is on the side of the
water the edge of the board and here we
use this typical scheme controlling
those squares to get the King into the
corner and win the game it's always this
type of check check check
this type of checkmate in the corner of
the board actually not that difficult if
you have any chess engine chess program
just set up this position and try to
make the computer can you manage it so
it's a good exercise just do this a
couple of times and you will see that
mating with two bishops is not very
difficult now to mating with Bishop and
Knight this is in fact funny endgame
where many strong players even struggle
so sometimes it's the case that they
have studied it as a kid and never had
it on the board so might have might have
forgotten forgotten it there are
examples where grandmasters didn't
manage to to mate with the ship at night
which is start the embarrassing but it
can sometimes happen if you have very
little time on the clock and are very
nervous that you that you screw up
things but normally a strong player
should manage
there's a Bernard now let's look at this
yeah meeting with Bishop Knight this is
a very important position and we should
start from here it's very important to
know that the black King can only be
mated in those corners of the board that
are of the color of the teching Bishop
so white can only make black on a 8 or H
1 those corners other only cones where
made can be forced this is also why
black very often defense by running into
the opposite corners like age 8 in this
case we need to know one very important
maneuver that is designed to push the
black King into the the right corner of
the corner where we can meet him and
this maneuver is started exactly in this
position that we have on the board it
turns out that from any given position
at the beginning of this endgame we will
always be able to force this type of
position note that it is not necessarily
exactly here it would be the same thing
yeah as a mirror image let's say with
the black king being on on c1 no white
bishop on c4 like like here you know
this is this the same thing it's just a
mirror image and yeah what is the
maneuver that we that we need to be
aware of it is some this maneuver a
knight maneuver 95 d7 c5 to be 7 this
series of night jumps that yeah quite
obviously looks like the letter W it's
nothing with george w bush it's this w
figure and this is some very important
to know how does the white start in this
position the key move is
to age seven this forces the black king
to go to aid and now we come to the
first important situation if wife now
goes over with the king he has not
gained anything black will come back and
threaten King g7 so this is not helping
what he needs to do is to make the first
step of this important W manoeuvre black
now should try King the eight trying to
escape if he steps to f8 the situation
is rather easy for what he can give this
check King ed and now with King e6 King
the 8th King t6 and King aid Jack check
King here we have basically reached the
same situation like at the beginning
only with two files to the left which
enormously helps us we will later see
that we will get this position in the
main line let's say as well but only
with more moves King the 8th is the
toughest defense and now we see where
this W maneuver kicks in King e6 King c7
and for a moment it looks like the black
King will escape but we have 97 taking
into patrol those two squares King c6
and now the all-important move Bishop d3
and now we see how those cooperation
between Bishop and Knight is working out
the bishop of course must control light
squares and can control other squares
and the knight controls the dark squares
we have a perfect cage-like needs to
step back with the King King to c7 and
to Bishop before again taking away this
Square and those squares control
by the night Black has step back King
the 8th King d6 King head south of g6 in
this position we had before when black
was going to f8 instead of the 8th King
to d8 and Bishop f7 the same situation
as in the beginning only two files to
the left King to c8 of course the only
move 95 continuing this maneuver 95 King
to the 8th Jack the check of the squares
controlled King c8 kim c 6 t b8 king b6
can see 8 and the check again check and
we have managed the same thing just
shifted to the side of the board where
we can actually meet him now blacks King
is caged in very nicely can only do this
side steps
now we just need to meet him 95 King 8
Bishop d7 or any other square on the
diagonal there are some others King here
jack Knight check King 8 checkmate and
the checkmate this is the typical
checkmate with night in Bishop the
knight is on this square here some si6
controlling b8 and on the long diagonal
of core services this deadly check it is
absolutely important to know the
starting position where Bishop h7 is the
key move and then this w maneuver of the
night if you know that you have all the
important tools to to win the same game
the second thing is of course you need
to push the King in the corner first and
we can look at this as well how does a
white accomplish that pushing the King
into the corner let's look at an example
for that this position is quite funny as
it is the worst possible starting
position for white normally you would
have some more active pieces but of
course even here a mate can be
accomplished rather easily white must
activate his piece of skin B to 1933
93 in d4 King c2 and we need to
step-by-step gain space sorry in this
concrete example is King III check King
D form and it should be 3 we see that
the knight is controlling squares the
bishop is controlling squares and the
King so we have a cooperation of all
pieces this is the only way to push the
black King back King in for King 3/3
kingi 593 m v king before so we had
activated our pieces now from the corner
and now we can start to to push black
back three track looking F 675 so we are
close now we close to getting him on the
side of the board
King G seven or maybe King King u g5 is
just as good and King you fall and we
see squares are controlled King f6 and
King f4 King g7 he wants to go in this
corner of course because they cannot be
mated here teenage 795 King edge eight
and you see we are very very close just
not something like seven eight
yeah okay so King to f6 and King age
seven and what we really only need is
the starting position we don't need to
reinvent the wheel here find the mid or
anything we just want the starting
positions where we know that we have a
checkmate
so basically Bishop b4 King h8 9 f7 King
g8 not f7 King f8 Bishop page 7 and this
is the starting position where we can
win with this typical W maneuver pushing
the King to the side just requires a bit
of patient and piece coordination note
that quite typically this is not
achieved by giving checks you want a
good cooperation coordination between
the pieces the night typically looking
at dark squares like here for example
looking at dark squares and occupying
the
are controlling those and the bishop
with the control of the light squares of
course this way you really quickly get
him where you want the king if he does
not go into the the dark square cone
here but tries to escape on the other
side always remember this is where we
want him if he is going over here it's
no problem at all we want him there
something like that
this cannot irritate us the least bit
because this is where he is going to get
meet it anyway something like this for
example note controlled controlled
controlled this would be a really easy
way to checkmate like something like
that for example yeah and this is not
going to end well
check check
checkmate and again a mate in the in
this corner it is not so difficult the
only way to really make sure you're not
screwing up this end game is to put it
on the board and practice it against the
front or against an engine against the
computer this is really a very reliable
way to to make sure you you actually can
do it over the board
I I have practiced this when I was when
I was a kid really really a lot against
the computer until the point where I
really managed to do it quite reliably
and it does happen on the board it
absolutely does
I had it only once as a defender where
my opponent managed to make me but he
didn't really know what what he was
doing it was very lucky he made it on
the 48 of the 50 moves that he
available to do it so really a practice
practice practice the cent games to make
sure you can can do it if it it really
pops up make sure you note the you know
the W maneuver and practice those
pushing this pushing working towards the
the edge of the board yeah I hope you
enjoyed this first episode this first
part of the basic end games I hope that
even for more advanced players maybe
this Knight and Bishop endgame was was
helpful and I will continue this yearís
with lots of ant games and in the future
if you feel like you're not sure if this
is some helpful for you or maybe you
think it's too easy just look briefly at
the video and go through it quickly with
fast-forward and see if there's
something that might be of interest to
you I want to make those videos for a
wide range of a wide range of audience
so I don't want to do advanced videos
only so um yeah to check if it's if it's
for you if not other players will
definitely definitely like it okay
thanks for watching